>> Hi, everyone.
My name is Billy and I am here to talk to
you about making art with virtual reality.
A bit about myself, I work in San Francisco
at a company called Opendoor.
We buy, renovate and sell homes.
Please come say hi if you would like to chat
with me about it.
I organize a MOJT monthly meet up called WaffleJS.
We just celebrated our three-year anniversary
so I am pretty happy.
This is my handle on Twitter where I will
tweet out a link to my slides and demo later
today.
Let's start talking about the buzzy thing
of the moment, virtual reality.
When I think of virtual reality I find it
a bit overwhelming.
At least in terms of the harder choices there
is a wide gamut.
You have the phone and box model where you
put your phone into Google card board and
play around with it.
At the highest end you have things like Vire
and hardware to show you where you are in
the room and trackers for your hands, as well.
On the software side, there is a lot of excitement.
Games with PlayStation, videos on YouTube
but none of these hit the mark and make me
think I really need to get a headset.
What is missing from the conversation is its
potential for making art.
Most of the mediums of art we interact with
have a lot of inherent restrictions.
There is only one given painting.
You cannot replicate or easy remix it.
For music and videos, you can duplicate them
but it is ultimately a one-way street and
you cannot meaningful interact with them.
For video games, you can interact but you
can't change them.
You are always playing within the confines
of the game.
With VR, we reached a paradigm shift.
It is interactive.
But with VR there is a large opportunity for
play and exploration especially with the ability
to remix other's work.
Because it is in its infancy we have the opportunity
to make interesting things.
I would like to re-create an instillation
piece by Yayoi Kusama called obliteration.
Yayoi Kusama is a Japanese artist and known
for large scale sculptures and instillation
pieces.
Procedure her signature motif is polka dots.
This is in Singapore.
In the center, you will see a pair of heels
with flowers coming out of them and that is
at San Francisco airport.
And then you have the mannequins covered in
wigs.
If you have been on Instagram you seen her
work.
Infinity room is her most famous work.
It feels like you are suspended in space which
is an interesting sensation.
The piece I would like to re-create is called
obliteration room.
It is an all-white room and visitors are given
stickers and invited to stick them all over
the room.
This piece is radically different.
With most art pieces, there is a divided line
between the viewer and artist.
The artist is mentally separated by having
to know a lot about the artist, piece itself
and historical context to understand it.
Even if the viewer is allowed to interact,
it is not meaningfully changed as a result.
Obliteration breaks down the barrier between
the artist and viewer.
The piece changes as the visitor interacts.
I found this striking because when was the
last time you saw both parents and children
having fun in a museum together?
This piece is meant for everyone.
The young, old, and the everyday person.
This is what I meant by us reaching a paradigm
shift with VR.
It is not like video games where it is interact
but not meaningful changed through interaction.
It is like all these things and a new medium
for us to play with.
As I thought about re-creating the obliteration
room, I throughout about making it personal.
Instead of having to pay to go to museums
to interact with an art piece, anyone could
come into my apartment and put stickers everywhere.
The thought of making art more accessible
to a larger group of people made it really
exciting to me.
To re-create this piece, we are going to use
a framework called A-Frame.
First we will create an all-white scene with
white furniture.
Then we will create stickers on the fly in
the scene.
Then we will add an interaction and physics
to the scene to make the stickers fly around
and stick to things.
A-Frame is a WebVR framework created by Mozilla
build on top of Three.js.
It is easy to set-up and has syntax that you
can declare A box in HTML and it will render
A box like you are seeing.
It is really powerful, too.
You can use it to create hypnotic visualizations
like this with -- which kind of look like
a '60s music video.
And you can create interact games like this
where for some reason you are shooting a bunch
of smiley faces flying around in space.
It supports the full range of devices from
the phone in a box model to dedicated devices
like HCC vibe with positional trackers.
So, let's get started.
We will first create the scene for us to pour
walls and furniture into it.
We can start by setting up a scene by declaring
a scene at the top.
You will notice I am using pug instead of
regular HTML and we will declare a scene at
the top and create the floor by declaring
A-plane and the dividing wall with A-box.
Now that we have set-up the structure of the
room let's start adding furniture.
For the demo, we can use Google Poly which
is a library of 3D models.
You can download ones and remix them or create
new ones yourself and update them.
You can find single models which is a snake
that kind of looks like a boot Emoji which
is fun or you can find complex ones like this
where it is a composite of many models.
You have a tree, campfire, sleeping bag, and
a lot of things going on in this one.
For these 3D models you will notice you get
two files instead of one.
One is the object file which represents the
skeleton of the model, the physical shape
of the thing, and the other is the material
file which represents the skin of the model
as in the materials and the colors of the
thing.
In this example, one dining set is rendered
with both object and material file and the
other one is rendered with just the object
file.
So you can see here that the one that is rendered
with just the object file is pure white which
is what we want.
Since that is what we want, we will be rendering
all models with just the object file instead
of both the object and material file.
To load these files into our scene, we will
first need to use A-Frame's asset management
system.
A-frame preloads and caches 3 D models before
rendering.
With the asset management system, we can store
3D models and audio and other things.
At the top we will be declaring A assets and
for each object we want to load in we will
declare A-asset item and for each item giving
it a unique ID we will use later in the scene
for reference it.
Later on, the file will be declaring A entity
which as a generic container for things.
It is like the div for A-frame.
We will load in an object model file we declare
using the unique ID we declared earlier on.
So as we load object into our system, sometimes
they will be way too big or too small and
I personally find it hard to reason about
3D spaces on a 2 D screen.
A-frame's debugging helps with this.
You can scale things up and down, move it
around, just to get the riot placement.
It is like the building in Sims when you are
buying furniture and building walls and things
like that.
As you look through the Google Poly library
you may not find what you want.
I was looking for a coffee table like this
and this is an opportunity to create a model
of our own using primitives.
The coffee table can be broken down into a
cylinder and four box elements for the legs.
You can right code like this to create a coffee
table out of primitives.
First declaring A-cylinder to create the surface,
and adding in boxes for the legs, and then
wrapping in a single A-entity tag to make
it clear this is just one thing.
Here is how it looks in the demo.
You can see that because we created it ourselves
using primitives you can play around with
it more in the debugging interface.
If you don't feel like the leg placement is
right, or the surface could be bigger or smaller,
you can get a feel for it in the debugging
interface instead of changing numbers and
refreshing constantly.
We can do the same thing for other bits of
furniture, too.
I wanted to put in a console like this but
I could not find a Google Poly with so I tried
to make it myself.
This one didn't turn out quite well like the
other one.
I think I will try to make it better in the
next version.
So far we have built our apartment, moved
in, and arranged our furniture.
You can see that it is a bit eerie and hard
to see because of the low contrast.
It kind of reminds me of the white room in
2001 space Odyssey but in kind of a bad way.
To make it better, let's try adding some lighting.
A-frame makes it easy to at -- add lighting.
There are five types and we will use ambient
and point to build our scene.
Ambient lights affect all entities in a scene
are not dependent on position.
You can use this to make sure the darkest
shadow in the scene is not black but dark
gray.
Point lights affect entities all-around them
in all directions and are dependent on positioning.
This is useful to simulate things like light
bulbs which we will be doing in our scene.
Next, I will go over the three other lighting
types briefly.
So, spotlights are kind of like point lights
but they don't light up in all directions.
They only point in one direction like a spotlight.
Directional lights simulate things like the
sun and shines at a specific direction, but
it is positioned agnostic.
For our scene here, it would kind of make
it look too moody like Sin City so that is
no good.
And hemisphere lights are the last one.
This might be useful for creating a hot bling
video.
You can declare a type here which are ambient,
directional, hemisphere or spot.
For each lighting type there are additional
primers.
You can set decay and distance, for example.
In this example, you will notice as soon as
you add lighting to any object in the scene
it turns off the default lights meaning we
have to be more intentional about where and
how we place our lighting elements.
To figure out the exact coordinates in the
lighting options we can play around with it
in the debugger.
Here we are playing with decay, distance,
and intensity to see what feels right for
the scene.
For each additional lighting source you add,
it add said performance implications because
the engine has to calculate how each lighting
interacts with each other.
I had around 12 lighting sources at the beginning
of the demo and gave me below 11LPS and it
was terrible.
I went down to three and that keeps it above
30.
This is what the finished product looks like.
With custom lighting, there is higher contrast
and you can see the dining room set, TV and
the rest of the apartment sed of looking eerie
and low contrast and, kind of, bizarre.
Now that we have placed our lighting sources,
we can start thinking about stickers.
First how to generate the stickers and orient
them in the right direction and then how to
throw them and get them to stick on things.
We need to generate the sticker where the
user is and query the A-camera element for
the position.
Here is our code on how to add a sticker to
the scene.
It is pretty simple.
First you get there coordinates of the camera,
then we generate a cylinder of the appropriate
size, then we set the position value to be
where the camera is positioned, and finally
we append it to the scene.
You can see here as we spun the sticker, you
will notice the sticker is also facing up.
It feels more natural for the sticker to face
you as you spun it and we need to know the
direction the camera is facing.
This part is more complicated than grabbing
the camera and requires a bit more vector
math.
As you play around in the inspector, we can
see we want to rotate the sticker along the
X axis up and down and Y axis as you look
side to side.
These rotations should be set in a way they
are always facing us.
When you call this function, you mean get
back three numbers that represent which direction
you are looking at in 3D space.
X is side to side and Y is up or down.
Here is a diagram that might help explain
what is going on.
The camera is facing due north, X is 0, Z
is 1, when facing south, X is 0 and Z is negative
1.
The issue here is that regardless of whichever
direction we are facing the stickers are spawning
up.
We want to position the sticker where the
camera is facing and rotate the sticker in
such a way it is facing the camera.
We can do this by taking input of X and Y
coordinates and its direction and use those
numbers to output the correct X and Y rotations
of the stickers.
For me, it is hard to think about taking three
directional values and output two rotational
values.
Let's considered the case when the camera's
direction is pointed at the northern half
of the screen when Z is greater than or equal
to 0 and then we can flip the Y value for
when Z is less than 0.
You can see the rotation remains the same
whether you are facing due north or south,
but when facing northeast, the rotation is
a mirror image when you are facing southwest
and same for northwest.
After playing around with the inspector, we
can determine the directional value of Y and
negative and positive 1 should match 0-180.
We can create a linear scale with the appropriate
domain and range.
We do the same for the X axis rotation taking
in the directional X value.
When we detect the Z value is less than 0
we multiply and flip it.
After you make the calculation, we set the
rotation values.
This is a reminder this is how the stickers
used to spun.
They would always face up no matter where
you are or which way you are facing.
With the changes, you can see the stickers
are always facing us no matter which way we
face.
We have covered how to position the sticker
correctly and set the rotation such that it
always faces us and next is figuring how to
launch the sticker.
A-Frame doesn't come with physics out of the
box and doesn't have gravity, collision events
and dynamic motion.
Thankfully there is a great package called
A-Frame physic systems which is built on top
of canyon.js.
Before I can get started with adding emotions,
we should talk about bodies.
Bodies can interact and surround with the
entity.
There is dynamic bodies that move freely and
they also fall if gravity is enabled.
Static bodies are fixed or animated in a fix
way and when they collide with other objects
their static bodies are unaffected.
If produced with the static bodies, for example,
yeah, the sofa's dynamic body would go flying
as we put stickers on it.
We would want furniture and walls to be static
so when the sticker collides with them they
should not move.
We want the stickers to be dynamic as they
fly through the air but when they hit something
they should stick and remain stuck.
With this in mind, let's start putting motion
into scene.
We need to get the vector the direction the
camera is facing so we can set the velocity.
Keep in mind, we do this after the physics
body has loaded which happens after the initial
rendering.
At this point, we have managed to generate
stickers in the correct position and launch
them in the in the direction we are looking
at.
We can see the sticker is simply bouncing
off the furniture and walls instead of sticking
and this is because the stickers remain dynamic
bodies after colliding.
We will create coalition event listeners on
the stickers to fix this.
When the sticker collides with an object,
we can check to see if it collided with a
static body and then we know it is the walls
or furniture and it should stick.
At that point, we can have it remain stationary
by turning it into a static body.
Here we can see as soon as the sticker hits
a static body it turns into a static body
itself.
That makes it stop moving and makes it look
like it is sticking to the sofa.
In the previous clip you will notice the stickers
don't stick perfectly on the surface of the
models and this is because how the physic
engine interprets models.
They don't respect the curvature or the individual
cushions on the sofa and this is because the
physic engine interprets them as primitive
shapes and this makes the engine more performing.
You can see how the physic engine sees each
model in the debug mode.
You can see the engine sees the plant is a
box instead of the individual leaves or pot
it sits in.
There is a slight bug with the physics engine.
With you create a custom non-primitive entity
and rotate it, the custom is rotated but the
physic body is not.
You can see it is orthogonal to the thing.
We can manually create the physics body.
First, create a primitive that most closely
fits the model.
A-box element that is a static body and then
place it like so; then make it invisible and
you are done.
I like to close out with the demo of what
the actual final product looks like.
The demo is obviously not a perfect creation
of the obliteration room but I think we managed
to get pretty far.
We covered a few things like generating a
scene, adding in models and lighting, dynamically
generating elements, adding in a physic engine
and interaction, and modifying bodies.
This barely scratches the surface of what
you can do in VR.
Some of my favorite VR paintings are till
brush paintings.
You can see this accomplishes what you can't
do with other paintings and conveys depth.
You can see under the water, there are fish
swimming in the water.
You can see underneath the boat and inside
the house.
Unlike a sculpture, you can download and remix
it to make your own and others can download
and remix it.
Because it is VR it can be meaningful interactive.
I encourage all of you to go out there and
make something.
A 360-video game, a 360 video, a game, a till
brush painting.
VR is still unchartered territory and everybody
is trying to figure it out.
Embrace the novelty of it.
Thank you for coming to my talk and thank
you to JSConf for having me.
And you can find the demo in this reel over
here.
This is my handle on Twitter where I will
tweet out a link to my slides later on today.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]